[Musique]
bonsoir c'est lors d'auditions publiques
notre rendez vous hebdomadaire et cp
assemblée nationale public sénat le
figaro une heure de débat ensemble de
confrontation une heure de démission
pour aller sur le fond des sujets pour
tout comprendre pour faire le point et
notre invité aujourd'hui et
françois-xavier bellamy bonsoir vous
êtes député européen les républicains et
chef de la médiation les républicains au
parlement européen au cours de cette
émission vous allez être interrogé par
mes consoeurs des chaînes parlementaires
qui vont nous rejoindre tout à l'heure
un député un sénateur français qui vont
vous posez des questions sur l'europe
sur les enjeux aussi en france et puis
pour conclure on accueillera yves
thréard leur garde yves thréard du
figaro
et puis sans oublier les questions des
téléspectateurs que les téléspectateurs
peuvent nous faire parvenir par le biais
du figaro live et que je vous
transmettrai au fur et à mesure
selon l'entente que nous aurons mais on
aura sept ans j'espère on va commencer
par l'élimination du porte parole de
l'organisation état islamique et al
bagdadi par l'armée américaine en syrie
est ce que vous direz que c'est un bon
point pour donald trump
c'est d'abord un grand pas pour la paix
et la sécurité du monde et de ce point
de vue là oui nous pouvons remercier nos
alliés américains et tous ceux qui avec
eux je crois que les kurdes notamment et
y ont contribué ont participé à cette à
ce succès un bon point pour donald trump
c'est tellement important que ce serait
absurde y voir un enjeu politicien
évidemment que c'est un bon point pour
donald trump mais je crois que c'est un
bon point est encore une fois un atout
pour pour pour la lutte contre le
terrorisme islamiste et pour la victoire
c'est ce que vous dites mais c'est ce
que ne dit pas emmanuel macron
christophe castaner qui dit attention il
y à des risques de résurgence
éventuellement d'attac ou de volonté de
vengeance vous ne partage pas ce point
de vue aussi bien sûr évidemment la
lutte contre le terrorisme islamiste
n'est pas terminé avec la mort d' un
bogue al-bagdadi puisque il s'agit
seulement d'une étape on sait que l'état
islamique a perdu ici un pièce
importante de son organisation on sait
aussi que bien sûr et je crois que le
ministre l'intérieur est plaisant
n'aurait plus dans tout à fait raison
d'appeler à la vigilance
une telle situation peut conduire à une
volonté de revanche et à des actes
de violence sur notre sol c'est une
étape c'est peut-être une bataille de
gagnée mais ce n'est pas la fin d'une
guerre qui elle va certainement se
prolonger on va accueillir maintenant
tam tran huy depuis que senna et
brigitte boucher de lcp
[Musique]
c'est bon à savoir thème traduit non sa
franchise merci d'être avec nous ce soir
c'est un plaisir et on va commencer par
ceux les débats que nous connaissons en
france autour notamment de la laïcité
tam effectivement un puisque emmanuel
macron a reçu aujourd'hui ce matin même
les représentants du cfcm le cfcm
le conseil français du culte musulman le
président de la république les a
exhortés à être plus offensive contre
l'islamisme et le communautarisme est ce
que le csm doit apporter des gages plus
qu'il n'en a fait jusque là il faut
certainement que les musulmans de france
travaillent sur la meilleure manière de
lutter contre la radicalisation qui peut
menacer dans leurs rangs ils en ont pas
fait assez jusqu'ici pour vous il faut
aussi que l'état prenne ses
responsabilités et je crois que le rôle
des politiques n'est pas d'abord de dire
ce que les croyants devrait fermer de
garantir le cadre républicain
à l'intérieur duquel effectivement la
radicalisation peut être prévenue
empêcher mais ce sont des fausses sur le
nom je pense que c'est un discours de
vérité qu'il est important de tenir mais
encore une fois ça n'exonère pas le
président de la république de sa propre
responsabilité
vous voulez un grand discours sur la
laïcité c'est ça que vous attendez du
président il faut sans doute une parole
claire est en effet beaucoup
d'observateurs et comme beaucoup
d'acteurs de la vie publique reconnaît
ce qu'aujourd'hui cette parole manque du
point de vue du côté du chef de l'état
il faut aussi des actions claires il ya
quelques il ya quelques jours le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a été
attaquée et même menacés sur les ondes
de rfi par yassine belattar qui se dit
d'ailleurs proche du président de la
république en tous les cas qui semble
avoir eu une proximité avec lui il a dit
qu'il n'était pas le bienvenu dans le 80
que jean-michel il a laissé entendre que
jean michel blanquer re pourraient être
menacés s'ils se rendaient dans le
département de seine-saint-denis ce qui
est une manière là c'est parce qu'il
avait osé dire effectivement qu'il lui
semblait que le voile n'était pas
souhaitable dans la société française
c'est sûr trier
et surtout il lui semblait et ça c'est
un point qui me paraît décisif que
l'éducation nationale ne devait pas être
le lieu où on en fait la promotion
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez en venir
au tour donné je crois qu'il est temps
que le chef de l'état tranche ce débat
et notamment sur la question de la place
du voile à l'intérieur de l'institution
scolaire il ya une loi en 2004 qui a été
votée pour faire en sorte que le voilà
jeté
je termine juste sur ce point en 2004 on
a voté une loi
cette loi a été fondamental je ne sais
pas si on serait capable de la voter
encore aujourd'hui dans le contexte
actuel et il reste un point à clarifie
qui est la place des accompagnatrices
scolaire qui portent le voile pour
entourer des sorties scolaires et qui
donc contribuer d'une certaine manière
au service public de l'éducation
nationale on attendrait que le président
de la république agissent sur ce sujet
la dieppoise est une donne sa réponse
m'a dit il ya un amalgame
il ne faut pas confondre une forme
d'islamophobie et le port du voile dans
l'espace public exige même ce n'est pas
mon à fond on est tous d'accord pour
dénoncer l' amalgame qui consisterait à
faire en sorte que des personnes qui
portent le voile soit suspecté de
terrorisme et on voit d'ailleurs d'une
certaine manière dans l'attaqué qui a eu
lieu aujourd'hui contre une mosquée que
cet amalgame produit aussi de la
violence et qu'il produit d'autant plus
de violence qu'on a le sentiment que
l'état est défaillant pour faire son
travail ce travail là il devrait être
fait d'une manière absolument
irréprochable et moi je n'attends pas
seulement du président de la république
il exhorte le cfcm à faire le ménage
dans ses rangs mais que le président de
république traitement se donner le
prénom la république soutiennent le
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
la parole qu'il a prises qui le
soutiennent face aux menaces dont il a
été l'objet qu'il ait une parole de la
sq avec ensuite une belattar et
concernant virgile de saisir via que je
me posais pas absolument se voir barnier
vous la bourgogne et je ne savais pas
mais c'est pour dire qu'on est dans une
situation où la parole du président est
absente alors même que l humoriste se
permet de faire comme si il y avait
aujourd'hui une partition du territoire
national ces partitions dont avait parlé
françois hollande qui ferait qu' un
ministre de la république ne pourraient
plus entrer dans un département où il a
servi comme recteur au motif qu'il
aurait eu un jugement négatif sur le
voile c'est très grave comme situation
et le président la république
aujourd'hui sur les changements qu'il ne
faisait pas mal
il explique ça ne prend pas la mesure
contre le communautarisme c'est le bon
débat final mais lutter contre le
communautarisme ça veut dire être
capable de montrer que le chef de l'état
prend des décisions claires et
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui je crois
puisque vous parlez de yassine belattar
qu'est-ce qu'il devrait prendre comme
décision
il faudrait d'abord que il donne tort à
yassine belattar en soutenant la
proposition de jean michel blanquer
d'interdire le voile pour les
accompagnatrices scolaire c'est parce
que je crois c'est une manière d'aller
au bout de la logique de la loi de 2004
position de jean michel branquart lui
c'est ce que j'en achète blanquart a
même laissé entendre
c'est ce qu'il avait laissé en soi bien
sûr vous allez commencer à faire
référence au climat actuel avec
notamment cette attente a aujourd'hui à
la mosquée de bayane tout d'abord votre
wii c'est justement cette cire déjà vous
parler du contexte vous est liée au
contexte d'après vous bien sûr c'est lié
à ce débat assez catastrophique dans
lequel on s'engage aujourd'hui parce que
ce débat n'a aucune espèce de clarté et
que vous savez je crois assez c'est pour
revenir à mon terrain de prédilection
quand on quand on fait de la philosophie
politique au fond on voit toujours que
la politique est une sorte de miracle
fragile qui nous permet de transformer
nos désaccords en conversation plutôt
qu'en violence et à chaque fois que la
politique échouent la violence que je
suis ressurgit à chaque fois que l'état
est incapable à la faillite sucre
aujourd'hui on est dans un climat
d'islamophobie c'est ça que vous
dénoncez en tous les cas on est dans un
échec de la part de la classe politique
et plus précisément encore de ceux qui
nous gouvernent pour faire en sorte
d'apporter une réponse à cette
inquiétude des français
et si cette réponse ne vient pas de
l'état alors le danger est grand en
effet que la fracture ne se fasse sentir
et à toutes les questions sur
l'islamophobie zone islamophobie la vie
hier des manifestations
vous pensez qu'on est dans un climat
d'islamophobie de stigmatisation des
musulmans aujourd'hui en france je ne
crois pas que la société française soit
islamophobe d'ailleurs c'est assez
extraordinaire au contraire de voir à
quel point
pardonnez moi dans le jdd qui dit que
61% des français pensent que l'islam est
incompatible avec les valeurs de la
société française et 83% dans vos rangs
a lâché les réputations dire que la
laïcité est précieuse dans notre société
ça n'est pas être islamophobe et c'est
là le glissement très dangereux qu'on
voit aujourd'hui si la société française
était globalement raciste si elles
étaient globalement islamophobe
si elle était traversée de façon très
profonde par ces tendances
de haine il est évident que après les
attentats que nous avons connus répété
au cours des dernières années on aurait
vu des manifestations de violence et de
vengeance qui aurait été sans doute
assez terrible ça n'a pas été le cas et
on peut je ne le dis pas pour pour pour
pour considérer que la situation est
très heureuse et que tout va bien mais
je peux quand même dire nous pouvons
dire ensemble que c'est assez beau de
voir que la société française a su faire
preuve de résilience et qu'elle a montré
sa capacité à vivre ces moments de
tension sans jamais répondre par une
forme de vengeance voulu dire qu'à
passer ce qu'il faut dire qu'il ya pas
aujourd'hui je crois pas qu'ils aient de
climat global d'islamophobie et de haine
mais il est très clair que si l'état ne
sait pas répondre à cette inquiétude
alors oui c'est vrai malheureusement on
verra cette violence augmenté et je ne
le justifient pas mais je dis qu'il est
temps de réagir
ça n'est pas chez nous c'est gérard
collomb ministre public
aujourd'hui nous sommes côte-à-côte
demain peut-être nous serons face à face
on ne peut pas ne pas prendre cet
avertissement au sérieux il ya le débat
qui leur revient au sénat demain
effectivement avec la droite sénatoriale
qui présente une proposition de loi une
proposition de loi qui concerne tous les
signes religieux ça concerne toutes les
religions est ce que ça vous êtes
d'accord pour interdire tous les signes
religieux ostensibles aux
accompagnateurs de sorties scolaires ont
noté que soit l'heure du jour bien sûr
mais il est très évident qu encore une
fois quand vous contribuez au service
public de l'éducation
vous assumez la laïcité qui est le
propre des agents de l'état même quand
vous en êtes un collaborateur
occasionnel que le bénin fois je le voi
vous mettez ça sur le même niveau sur ma
faim soyons très sérieux aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas des gens qui arrivent avec une
grande croix ça n'est pas des gens qui
portent donc ces deux parts constituant
la difficulté la question c'est
effectivement ce qui est en train de se
produire dans certains de nos quartiers
ou de manière manifeste nous voyons une
société qui se transforme en addition de
communauté qui s'éloignent les unes des
autres en plaques tectoniques qui se
séparent progressivement et c'est
évidemment à l'intérieur aujourd'hui de
l'islam que se font jour des tendances
mais du coup pour faire une question sur
ce site et 83%
de sympathisants les républicains qui
pensent que l'islam est incompatible
avec la république aujourd'hui je pense
que la grande force de la république la
grande force pas seulement de la
république mais de la france c'est sa
capacité à intégrer c'est sa capacité à
assimiler
c'est sa capacité à rassembler je suis
enseignant j'ai commencé à enseigner
comme beaucoup de jeunes collègues dans
des quartiers où j'avais une immense
majorité de jeunes musulmans devant moi
dans ma classe jamais aucun d'entre eux
ne m'a refusé d'entendre des textes de
platon ou d'aristote de kant de eagle au
motif qu'ils auraient été européen dont
je termine c'est important la question
c'est qu'est ce que nous avons donné à
aimer à ces jeunes et aujourd'hui ça
fait trop longtemps que nous constatons
la faillite de l'intégration dans notre
pays sans apporter les réponses
nécessaires
je ne dis pas que l'islam soit on m'a
dit que je pense d'ailleurs que le dire
serait aggravée ce fossé mais la
question c'est comment est ce que nous
garantissons le cadre commun qui lui
pour le coup doit être non négociable
dans lequel des jeunes grandissent pour
qu'ils puissent se reconnaître dans la
france quelle que soit leur confession
la laïcité protège le fait de croire ou
de ne pas croire et je me permets de
dire d'ailleurs qu'on devrait garantir
dans notre pays que le fait de ne pas
croire ou le fait de ne plus croire le
fait de ne pas être croyant en l'islam
puisse être protégé respecter et faire
en sorte que chacun soit reconnu pour ça
alors ça mais il faut encore qu'elle
soit appliquée partout
tam est la même qu'avant c'est clair que
si nous donnons le sentiment de reculer
face à l'avancée d'une forme de
communautarisme ou d'une forme de
sécessionnisme qui s'exprime dans une
partie de la population
alors nous allons créer cette inquiétude
saviez bellamy vous êtes député européen
on connaît aussi bien votre attachement
à votre religion
en europe la question de sur la
reconnaissance des racines chrétiennes
de l'europe n'est plus à l'ordre du jour
parce que vous vous défendriez et bien
l'inscription de cette notion dans les
textes de l'union européenne est ce que
vous souhaitez qu'on relance ce débat au
niveau européen
moi j'ai défendu ce point pendant la
campagne pas seulement en parlant des
racines chrétiennes de l'europe mais en
parlant de tout ce qui a fait la
civilisation européenne c'est à dire de
son héritage gréco-latin de son héritage
judéo-chrétien de tout ce qui fait que
l'europe est ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et c'est très intéressant que vous me
posiez la question ça n'est en rien une
entorse à la laïcité c'est simplement
une manière de reconnaître un fait
historique et se sont inscrits et ce
fait historique chrétien et vous fait il
est l'islam sur la laïcité mais parce
que le christianisme
a contribué à former la civilisation
européenne est d'ailleurs le mot même de
laïcité vient de la tradition chrétienne
moi je crois qu'il faudrait pouvoir dire
ce qu'est l'europe ce qui à fait
l'europe pour cette raison les textes
fondateurs devient sur genève et voilà
cette raison pour cette raison que vous
évoquez un instant qui est qu' il faut
pouvoir dire quelque chose de notre
identité aux jeunes qui grandissent en
europe et qui doivent pouvoir se
reconnaître de cette civilisation de
l'europe toujours et de sujets qui nous
concernent également ce sont les
migrants parce qu'il ya encore des
migrants qui dérive au large en ce
moment et il ya eu un texte au parlement
européen thème traduit récemment
effectivement un texte au parlement
européen qui était une proposition de
résolution pour renforcer le sauvetage
des migrants un texte a été rejeté au
parlement européen à deux voix près
alors on en fait quoi là aujourd'hui de
ses 104 un migrant qui sont au large de
la libye pour vous nous le groupe ppe
nous avons effectivement voté contre ce
texte qui a été rejetée vous l'avais dit
à une courte majorité parce que ce texte
ne présentait pas les garanties qui nous
paraissait indispensable pour permettre
à nos pays d'assurer leur politique
migratoire d'une manière souveraine
d'une manière sûre et d'une manière sûre
aussi pour les premiers concernés c'est
à dire pour les migrants mais aussi pour
toutes les personnes qui sont jetés sur
les routes de la migration par des
réseaux de passeurs sans scrupules qui
leur vendent un eldorado en europe qu'en
réalité une hauteur du pont par le grand
danger at qu'ils le grand danger et
river vous fait qu avant d'arriver au
cas particulier parlons quand même de ce
cadre général mais j'y viens tout de
suite le grand danger c'est que si nous
faisons ce qui était le souhait d'une
partie des députés européens de la
gauche ou des verts
si nous faisons en sorte que tous ceux
qui prennent la mer soit ensuite
récupéré et conduit en europe où ils
pourront s'installer de manière sûre
alors évidemment nous jetons
littéralement en mer beaucoup de
personnes qui vont espérer trouver
l'occasion là d'entrée en europe non
résidents quatre là qu'il faut permettre
à ces personnes d'être en sécurité il
faut aller à leur secours seelanders en
rien pour pouvoir les recompte pour
pouvoir les reconduire ensuite vers le
port d'origine d'où ils viennent ouvert
un territoire sur où ils pourront être
accueillis à l'extérieur de l'europe
il n'y a aucune raison de faire en sorte
que ceux qui sont secourus en mer soit
automatiquement conduit vers un port
européen
surtout que d'ailleurs ils sont souvent
secours sauf que rock
près des côtes du nord dans ce pays pour
les sauver et éventuellement les
renvoyer dans leur pays c'est ce que
vous venez de dire le aujourd'hui on
sait très bien pardonnez moi que la
plupart des personnes qui demandent
l'asile en europe ne sont pas éligibles
et que l'immense majorité des personnes
qui ont demandé l'asile par exemple en
france ne sont jamais reconduits dans
leur pays
donc en réalité ce système qui consiste
à dévoyer le droit d'asile met en danger
des gens qui du coup vont s'embarquer
sur la mer en espérant y trouver une
porte d'entrée vers l'europe alors qu'en
réalité parfois ils y trouvent la mort
est souvent en fait nous devenons les
complices des passeurs par notre passif
d'un propos d'europe toujours la
nomination du futur commissaire européen
qui représentera la france
thierry bozon a été proposée par
emmanuel macron pour représenter la
france en tant que commissaire européen
est ce que vous allez voter pour lui eh
bien nous attendons les auditions qui
vont se dérouler c'est un processus
indispensable à priori sorte de garantir
bon mauvais candidat a priori il a les
qualités requises du point de vue des
compétences du point de vue de
l'expérience je ne fais pas partie de
ceux qui considèrent que pour pouvoir
assumer une fonction politique qu'il
faut ne pas avoir de passer et notamment
ne pas avoir touché à la vie de
l'entreprise au contraire cécile ménard
avait aussi ses qualités vous avez
rejeté sa candidature mais nous avons
reçu sa candidature pour une seule et
unique raison c'est qu'elle était
l'objet de deux enquêtes l'une au
parlement européen et l'autre en france
que ces enquêtes étaient toujours en
cours alors qu'elle l'avait conduite à
des conduites addictives
mais encore une fois la question n'était
pas de juger sylvie goulard
la question était seul bien sûr que non
nous avons seulement considéré qu'il
était difficile qu'elle puisse exercer
son mandat de commissaire de façon
parfaitement sereine alors que le jour
même de la présentation de la commission
européenne elle était convoqué devant un
juge
c'est cette même enquête qui l'avait
conduite à démissionner en 2017 alors
qu'elle même ne s'était pas aux taux
jugé elle n'a jamais remis en cause pour
elle même la présomption d'innocence
aurait été absurde et beaucoup de
parlementaires européens n'ont pas
compris pourquoi ce qui devait empêcher
quelqu'un d'être ministre à paris
pouvait l'autorisé à être que ça me fait
justement thierry breton il ya julien
aubert qui pointent des conflits
d'intérêts possibles piratages fournit
des services informatiques pour l'union
européenne il ya aussi une plainte qui a
été déposée par anticor en quoi est-ce
si différent de sylvie goulard lui bien
sûr il ya beaucoup de questions qui se
posent c'est la raison pour laquelle je
vous disais que nous attendons que le
processus d
chan se déroule nous nous jouons le jeu
des institutions européennes comme nous
l'avons fait pour sylvie colas nous
n'avons nous n'avons ni positif ni
négatif
il ya deux auditions qui vont avoir lieu
l'une devant la commission juridique
affaires juridiques qui va travailler
sur la question des conflits d'intérêts
et l'autre devant la commission de
l'industrie notamment où je siège qui va
permettre d'évoquer les questions de
stratégie industrielle et c'est
seulement au terme de ces auditions que
nous pourrons donner notre feu vert ou
non à thierry monnet il y à la question
du bric site
oui effectivement europe toujours et
c'est l'événement qui n'aura donc pas
lieu cette semaine c'est le break site
il est reporté à fin janvier 2020 encore
trois mois qu'est ce qui nous dit que
cela ne va pas encore recommencé dans
trois mois ce que ce n'est pas
l'histoire sans fin
pas forcément fin janvier il est reporté
au moment où les britanniques
accepteront l'accord qui est aujourd'hui
sur la table avec l'union européenne et
ce délai peut être plus court tout
dépend maintenant du parlement
britannique et la démocratie britannique
puisque boris johnson vient de convoquer
des élections générales
donc le le le sujet pour nous c'est de
faire en sorte que cet accord puisse
être validé par les britanniques
c'est très important parce que et pour
nous parlementaires les républicains au
parlement européen ce sera notre point
de vigilance constants il faut
absolument que cette sortie se fasse de
manière coordonnée avec un accord
c'est-à-dire était justement pour une
renégociation de cet accord est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous pensez qu'il faut
encore encore négocier avec avec la
grande bretagne non l'accord est sur la
table il a été accepté par et boris
johnson je n'étais pas pour la
renégociation de l'accord j'ai toujours
dit en revanche que ce qui était très
important
c'était qu'il puisse y avoir un accord
rien ne serait plus dangereux pour nous
qu'un break site sans accord pour nous
les français pour nos emplois pour notre
économie pour nos agriculteurs pour nos
pêcheurs qui serait directement impactés
si l'union européenne sortait si le
royaume uni sortait sans accord avec
l'union européenne donc tant qu'à faire
donnons quelques semaines de plus à la
démocratie britannique pour produire
enfin ce vote favorable mais nous avons
besoin d'un accord pour faire en sorte
effectivement de protéger les intérêts
des français et c'est notre première
préoccupation
on va parler aussi d'un sujet de société
qui vous tient à coeur parce que c'est
en débat en france c'est celui de la pma
d'un train de nuit
effectivement à la pma qui va bientôt
arriver en discussion au sénat ce sera
pour janvier 2020 est-ce que vous
vous attendez que l air au sénat les
républicains bloquent la pma au sénat
qui est un petit peu plus offensif que
ce que cela a été et bien sûr l'examen à
l'assemblée à l'assemblée au contraire
j'ai trouvé que le groupe ait l'air
avait été extrêmement impliqué dans la
discussion et on a vu dans ce débat je
pense que la leaf pour tous ept et puis
ça a été moins violent quand même ça a
changé et puis alors attendez
s'impliquait ne veut pas dire être
violent heureusement et j'espère que le
débat sera aussi respectueux aussi
serein et aussi qu'on s'assied il ya
quinze jours les autres beaucoup de il
n'y était pas
non pas du tout regardé les débats à
l'assemblée nationale
j'imagine que vous les avez regardés
j'imagine moi je les ai regardés grâce à
vous grâce au motion
je les ai regardés avec beaucoup
d'attention et j'ai vu des
parlementaires remarquable je pense à
thibaut bazin patrick hetzel annie
genevard marc le fur
je me bats tous les citer mais qui ont
fait un travail exceptionnel pour
pouvoir faire en sorte de faire entendre
la voix de tous ceux qui s'inquiètent de
cette réforme non seulement de
l'ouverture de la pma aux femmes seules
et aux couples de femmes et de tout ce
qui va autour de la pma et de tout ce
qui est également dans cette révision
générale des lois de bioéthique je pense
par exemple à la création des embryons
homme-animal je pense à la possibilité
de 2,2 de la conservation des ovocytes
ouverte d'ailleurs à des entreprises
privées et donc susceptible de devenir
un service marchand
tout cela pose des questions éthiques
considérable et moi je voudrais
simplement dire à tous les français qui
nous écoutent qu'il est absolument vital
de s'informer sur cette réforme qui peut
paraître technique mais qui engage
vraiment notre avenir et pas grâce et
grâce à grâce à vos chaises à gaza les
républicains et moi je fais confiance
évidemment au groupe l'est républicain
au sénat mais à tous les sénateurs pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que ce débat soit
traitée assas à son juste niveau et
faire entendre la voix effectivement de
tous ceux qui craignent que derrière
cette réforme il y ait des dérives très
graves pour ne pas la gpa sera pour le
prochain quinquennat
je vois que le vrai sujet c'est
effectivement un des sujets importants
c'est que on ne peut pas considérer que
l'on fait la pma pour toutes les femmes
au nom de l'égalité
et dire que ça n'ouvrira pas la voie à
la gpa se sont évidemment une chose et
on l'a capté la royal national on l'a vu
dans le débat à l'assemblée puisque dans
le débat à l'assemblée la majorité a
d'une certaine manière échappé au
gouvernement
en montrant que la cohérence de cette
réforme supposait d'aller jusqu'à une
forme de vers de deux pas
supplémentaires partagés quant au thème
traduit sur la taxe gars fassent un
sujet sur lequel la france a pris les
devants bruno le maire aimerait qu'il ya
un système commun à toute l'union
européenne est ce que pour vous c'est
souhaitable
et puisque c'est réalisable quand on
voit aujourd'hui le poids des gaffes à
leur capacité à risque ont tourné tout
les résultats
amazon qui sont mises en place
évidemment d'accord avec bruno le maire
sur ce point il est tout à fait
nécessaire que l'union européenne puisse
enfin se doter d'un instrument fiscal
susceptible d' harmoniser la fiscalité
sur l'échelle de l'europe c'est
réalisable oui je le crois
dans le dernier mandat européen on a vu
déjà de grands pas en avant qui ont été
effectués notamment sous l'impulsion de
madame v styger qui est commissaire
européen qui s'occupait de des questions
de concurrence et qui pour la première
fois à sanctionner google et à
sanctionner des états qui ne jouaient
pas le jeu de la fiscalité européenne on
doit considérer qu'il ya des fiscalités
qui sont manifestement disproportionnée
lorsque l'irlande par exemple ne jouent
pas le jeu et créer une forme de dumping
fiscal à l'intérieur de l'europe
il est facile de se rendre compte qu'il
ya un déséquilibre qu'il ne rêve merci
merci
brigitte saveurs de l'ordre mais à
l'intérieur de l'europe on doit pouvoir
le gardien c'est là qui réduit d'être
venu sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques et rendez vous lundi prochain
évidemment avec notre prochain invités
et beaucoup de questions en même temps
beaucoup de questions c'est à tous les
suit on va accueillir maintenant sur
tous vos collègues parlementaires
nationaux
[Musique]
bonsoir rachid tu es mal son sénateur ps
du val-d'oise et bonsoir ludovic madness
vous êtes-vous député la république en
marche de moselle on va commencer par
acheter mal parce qu'ils voudraient
revenir acheter mal sûr j'allais dire
votre conception de la laïcité
bonsoir une semaine amis je vous ai
beaucoup entendu parler de la laïcité
mais ce qui est pour moi le bien le plus
précieux de notre pays il faut la chaire
et il a cultivé chaque jour elle a
hésité il ya beaucoup de gens qui en
parlent
il faut que chacun est bien en tête que
c'est la loi 1905 qu'il faut que chacun
puisse avoir
vous êtes élu de la république et moi ce
qui me dérange ce qui m'interpelle c'est
votre mise en avant assez régulière de
vos convictions religieuses mais ce
n'est pas un griffes de ma part en tout
cas quand on est élu de justifier son de
position au nom de ses convictions
religieuses et cela est terminé ma
question si ça vous dérange pas je veux
dire que ça ouais c'est je pense que
quand on est vous comme là nous sommes
tous responsables politiques on a le
droit de croire ou ne pas croire comme
chacun des français mais je crois qu'on
a aussi cette obligation à ne pas mettre
en avant nos convictions
notre philosophie de vie pour porter à
son de position je pourrais parler d'un
pma vous venez d'évoquer une autre point
pardonner je crois que ça c'est vraiment
important je crois que je vous avais
expliqué pendant vous a expliqué tout à
l'heure qu'il fallait qu'une religion
particulier d'ailleurs je n'ai pas su
dire dire qu'elle était ou non
compatibles avec la république vous avez
pas une religion mais globalement sur la
laïcité je crois que vous avez encore
quelques progrès à faire
je crois que sur l'exactitude on peut
faire des projets ensemble
est ce que vous pourriez me citer
maintenant ou plus tard
prenez le temps pour vérifier que vous
voudrez nos téléspectateurs prend le
faire aussi une seule fois où j'aurais
appuyer une proposition politique sur
une conviction religieuse ça ne me fait
jamais rien dit je l'avais fait à la
main par exemple
par exemple au niveau de la pma vous
l'avez évoqué au début
votre campagne européenne mais avant au
mondial à l'époque du mariage pour tous
vous avez participé à des réunions qui
était et vous évoquez le fait de vos
convictions religieuses de
outre votre histoire personnelle pour
son jeu alors je vais rentrer parce
qu'elle existe nous assurera donc jamais
si vous avez fait l'intervention je n'ai
jamais caché quoi que ce soit de mes
engagements personnels et vous avez dit
que c'était au nom de ses engagements
personnels gm prenait pas position
jamais monsieur était mal je vous en
supplie regardez mais regardez ce qu'est
la vie je vous dis je vous assure je
suis passeur du fils et successeur de
philosophie pour moi rien ne compte plus
dans le débat public que ce soit sur le
plan intellectuel ou sur le plan
politique que d'asseoir les convictions
que nous défendons sur des raisons et
des arguments rationnels
je lutte depuis toujours contre le
communautarisme c'est à dire contre
l'idée que quand on rentre en politique
on défend les valeurs d'une communauté
je déteste le mot de valeur d'ailleurs
parce que je trouve que ce mot est
infiniment relativiste chacun ici ne
défend pas sa communauté
nous sommes là tous ensemble pour tenter
de servir le bien commun et le bien
commun
c'est ce qui motive notre engagement à
tous j'en suis convaincu le vôtre comme
le mien c'est ce qui fait que parfois
nous sommes en désaccord et c'est normal
d'être en désaccord sur des questions
compliquées mais nous devons toujours
traiter nos désaccords par le prisme de
la raison jamais monsieur tu es mal
jamais je ne me suis opposé ni hommage
pour tous ni à l'apn sera pour des
raisons religieuses jamais que après on
soit tous temps et que évidemment il
n'ya pas d'incohérence dans nos vies
entre ce que nous croyons du point de
vue de nos convictions personnelles et
ce qui fait notre engagement politique
avec sa dimension rationnelle
heureusement ce serait totalement
absurde d'être contradictoire et de dire
tout et son contraire selon le plan sur
lequel on s'exprime mais jamais je le
répète c'est très important parce que le
grand danger c'est que la société de
demain
la politique de demain ne devienne
l'occasion pour chacun de confronter des
valeurs avec d'un côté les musulmans qui
s'expriment contre les catholiques
contre les incroyants contre dès que
communauté je voudrais à ce serait avant
tout à l'heure face je vous transmets à
propos mais bon vous n'avez pas répondu
à la question d'un journaliste
j'espère que vous signez le surmoi sûr
qu'il va se reconnaissez votre erreur
que vous que vous aurez le courage et
les éléments je vous transmettrai merci
il y avait une de vos collègues qui
posait la question est ce que pour
monsieur ben ami l'islam est donc
compatible avec la république en gros
c'est ce que dit là bas sa place en
france
je rappelle que liszt un autre pays ne
date pas d'il ya quelques mois mais
c'est une des histoires notamment en
réponse les deux guerres mondiales et ce
que l'islam à sa place en france dans la
république française
mais c'est salutaire tinner le l'islam
n'est pas incompatible avec notre
technique à condition à la condition
comme d'ailleurs n'importe quelle autre
religion que l'islam s'accordent avec le
cadre de cette république et le cadre de
notre pays et je crois que effectivement
il est absolument nécessaire de rappeler
que quand on grandit en france quand on
vit en france
eh bien on reçoit la france comme un
tout et que cette france qu'on reçoit et
qu'on est cons et qu'on doit d'une
certaine manière ce chérir quelques
relances là elle ne se négocie pas elle
ne se découpe pas en vivant chez que
avec ludovic madec parce que vous êtes à
la tête de la commission des affaires
européennes à l'assemblée nationale non
j'étais l'ancien whip la commission
d'affaires ou im annonce alexandre wade
vous faites pas la tête vous êtes vous
en êtes membre d'un soulier évoqué à
propos de ce qu'on ait évoqué tout à
l'heure sur la nomination éventuelle de
thierry breton
le projet de création d'une haute
autorité de la vie publique au niveau
européen c'est le propre raison qu'on
des fadas par une partie des députés des
nouveaux députés français au parlement
européen de créer une nouvelle autorité
au niveau européen pour éviter justement
ces problématiques de problèmes de
patrimoine de travaux de travail
effectué avec des pays étrangers avec
d'autres sociétés avec des ong
est ce que vous êtes pour la création de
cette autorité au niveau européen
pourquoi pas c'est à dire une
proposition qui a été repris ont été
faites par paris reçus à la van der
leyen qui est la nouvelle présidente de
la de la commission open source xen amis
pourquoi seulement pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas oui ou non
oui d'accord enfin faisons le sam sam
paraît effectivement une bonne idée tout
ce qui pourra en tout les cas permettre
aux citoyens de retrouver confiance dans
leurs institutions et notamment dans les
institutions européennes sera bon je me
permets simplement de dire que j'ai
trouvé très surprenant que le président
de la république fasse cette proposition
au lendemain
l'échec de la candidature de sylvie
goulard je crois qu'il ya un moment où
il faut manifester un peu d'humilité et
à la veille de notre affaire qui est
passée un peu inaperçue mais qui à titre
personnel mais assez profondément
troublé comme vous le savez peut-être le
premier ministre maltais qui est membre
du groupe socialiste est accusé de faits
de corruption dans son pays en tous les
cas plusieurs de ses proches ont été
cités dans les spas nama papers une
journaliste qui a révélé ce fait a été
assassiné il y a deux ans maintenant et
l'anc est à malte est complètement
bloqué d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'institutions internationales dont le
parlement européen cherche à savoir
pourquoi cette enquête est bloquée et se
sont émus de cette situation auprès du
premier ministre maltais et l'on a
appris il ya quelques jours que monsieur
gothique était sur la liste de la
république en marche aux élections
européennes un ancien ministre
socialiste italien qui travaille
aujourd'hui pour edouard philippe à
matignon travaillait également pour le
premier ministre maltais cette étrange
premier ministre dont le moins qu'on
puisse dire qu'il n'est pas un exemple
en matière de transparence au niveau
européen
je crois qu'avant de proposer de créer
de leur profession de cela qu'il a
démissionné de ses fonctions
il a eu des civilisations de lapin il y
a été contraire marc eyskens cd et
l'affairé mills a été clair là-dessus en
expliquant qu'il répète toutes les
informations après la haute autorité
nous remplissons chacun le donner mais
je les relatives à leur maître avait
dans les actions d'al rebelles
à chaque fois le montrant à jour au
maroc et des modifications maintenant
c'est aussi pénal c'est quand même les
mangas justement d'éviter qu'il ya un
cas potentiel qui se remettent au niveau
du dispositif gouvernemental européen ou
national en proposant cette autorité
européenne pour éviter qu'ils aient des
problématiques parce que tous les pays
de l'ue ne communiquent pas entre eux et
aussi cette différenciation entre la
france et malte quand on est à
l'étranger
toutes les informations ne passe pas
d'affaires godzilla prennent le
communiqué surnom c'est mon pote de
communication je pense que sandro moggi
n'a pas donné toutes les informations
tournai la ville ait ainsi pas non plus
parce qu'ils faisaient du conseil auprès
du premie s'il n'était pas salarié
directement du premier
maintenant il a démissionné de ses
fonctions il faut apprendre de ses
erreurs et je pense qu'on a l'humilité
de reconnaître que on a fait aussi des
erreurs parce qu'on est un jeune parti
qu'on il ya pas mal de choses sont en
discussion que jours
mais sinon on l'a fait à plusieurs
reprises mais la vraie question c'est
est simple est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre la haute autorité au niveau
européen nous a dit pourquoi pas nous a
pas répondu je suis le discours
classique du poétique il retourne la
question il cherche alors je suis tout à
fait pour moi pour ma part je n'ai rien
à cacher j'ai aucun problème avec ça
donc je suis paumé je veux simplement
dire que aucune institution en tant que
telle ne résoudra la défiance qui pèsent
aujourd'hui sur la vie politique et que
nous subissons vous comme moi si nous ne
sommes pas capables de changer nos
pratiques et il me semble et c'est tout
ça que je voulais souligner qu'il est un
peu incongru de réclamer cette haute
autorité quand simultanément on à coup
sûr coup l'histoire de madame goulard
avec son travail pour l'institut bergren
l'histoire de monsieur gauzy avec son
travail pour le prémice maltais et il
reste encore beaucoup de questions à
élucider sur ce sujet et ma dernière
question du coup si vous me permettez de
vous envoyer une c est ce que vous
trouvez normal dans ces conditions et
après tout ce que je viens de dire est
sur lequel chacun pourra se renseigner
plus avant
est ce que vous trouvez normal que
monsieur gauzy deviennent parlementaire
en marche pour le parlement européen
dans quelques semaines après le break
site moi personnellement je trouve que
quand on prétend incarner la renaissance
ou de renouveau en europe
on devrait pouvoir prendre ses distances
avec des prestations aussi l'éclairement
aussi opaque aussi mon sentiment c'est
qu'il devait évidemment démissionner de
sa vie dans quelque chose de
complémentaire dans votre question c'est
qu'il faut attendre la fin de toutes les
questions qu'on se pose est ce qu'on n'a
pas toutes les réponses
en l'état il n'est pas encore le break
si t'as pas été enregistrés donc lyon
dans l'union européenne où nous avons
encore les nos amis anglais à partir de
là attendons déjà que cette enquête et
jusqu'au bout et on aura la réponse à
son bon on se retrouvera le 31 janvier
si vous voulez bien pour parler de ça on
va parler d'un autre sujet avec rachid
et mal c'est celui des retraites parce
que c'est un sujet qui intéresse la
france mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau
européen là aussi un chacun fait ce
qu'il veut mais on va parler de la
france en l'occurrence oui non moi c'est
pour pour avoir votre point de vue parce
que comme vous le savez mais parce que
vous êtes un
spectateurs avertis mena acteurs avertis
du monde politique la majorité en place
qu'il avait annoncé ne pas toucher au
départ à l'âge de départ à la retraite
est parti dans une réforme des retraites
qui manifestement a du mal puisqu'il ya
un premier rapport du haut commissaire
s'est avéré que les propositions
n'étaient pas très fondée il ya à la
fois une idée de on repousse quelque
part l'entrée mais le président disant
qui veut le faire et donc moi je trouve
que il ya un vrai sujet j'aimerais vous
entendre vous en tant que l air sur
cette idée de cette réforme des
retraites dont on sait aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a pas d'urgence financière à la
sphère quand on sait que le régime par
points qui peut être intéressant pose
d'énormes problèmes à beaucoup de nos
français compatriotes français
on va parler des régimes spéciaux 3% je
rappelle moi je vous jeudi à la fois les
avocats là les enseignants les infirmes
et c est donc on a là un risque je pense
d'explosion du modèle social parce
majorité là à savoir d'un recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite et une baisse
conséquence des pensions versées pour
ces décisions de la reconstruction et la
question serait de savoir vous au niveau
des mers quelle est votre position sur
ce projet là que nous socialistes nation
nous contestons nous combattons pas ce
montant une fois ça fait ça affaiblit le
modèle social et ça ne répond pas à
cette question parce que juste pour
conclure je rappelle qu'en plus 50% des
français qui partent en retraite passe
d'abord par la case chômage avant de
partir en retraite donc si on allonge on
ne fait que s'accroître ce problème la
famille soutenez-vous cette réforme des
retraites que présente emmanuel macron
la première difficulté c'est de savoir
quoi soutenir parce qu'aujourd'hui la
réforme
le mans qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle
est encore difficile à suivre
et je trouve que le processus en lui
même pour les français qui s'inquiètent
de leur retraite est particulièrement
anxiogène
on a eu le travail fait par jean paul
delevoye le rapport qu'il a produit
normalement un rapport c'est ce qui
précède l'écriture d'un texte de loi qui
permet ensuite d'avoir un vrai grand
débat au niveau national aujourd'hui le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'on ne
sait pas du tout vers où le président de
la république et sa majorité nous
entraîne on a une sorte d' aller retour
permanent
on nous a parlé d'un plan b qui
ressemblait à une forme de retour en
arrière maintenant le président de la
république nous dit que il ne se
laissera pas intimider et qu'il compte
aller jusqu'au bout mais jusqu'au bout
de quoi on n'en sait toujours trop rien
mon deuxième sentiment c'est qu'il faut
dire la vérité aux français
et là pour le coup ce sera sans doute un
point de désaccord avec vous il n'y a
pas d'urgence 112 aujourd'hui mais il ya
un vrai sujet est un vrai sujet c'est
que la durée de vie et c'est une chance
s'est allongé que par conséquent nous
avons aujourd'hui plus de temps à la
retraite et que nous sommes d'ailleurs
le pays en europe où les français
passent le plus de temps où les
habitants passent le plus de temps de
leur vie à la retraite et donc il ya une
vraie question de justice donc c'est à
dire les générations que déjà le départ
qui est qu' il faut évidemment est ce
qu'il fait ou non pour le départ à la
retraite plus énorme saison avant les
france évidemment favorable au fait
qu'ils font qu'elle a les français
travaillent plus longtemps et ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que je crois que les
skis et ski et ses détracteurs tourne
qu'elle a c'est que je termine juste
avant d'en venir à cette question là ce
qu'est ce qui est un vrai problème c'est
quand c'est quand on ne dit pas la
vérité aux gens j'ai du mal à comprendre
que le président de la république et
commencer sa réforme en disant cette
réforme ne fera aucune économie alors
qu'en réalité est évidemment le but
semble bien être d'en faire qu'on nous
dise qu'on ne va pas reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite alors qu'évidemment
parler d'âge pivot c'est reculer l'âge
de départ à la retraite
il faut dire la vérité aux français
alors pouvez vous avez béziers ensuite
un débat démocrates ont vous la vérité
c'est quoi si vous vous demandez la
suite thema la vérité c'est qu'il faut
et là pour le coup je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de la question donc je ne
prétends pas posséder la vérité sur le
sujet mais la base de départ me semble
être qu'il faut que nous puissions
travailler plus longtemps jusqu'à quel
âge mais encore une fois j'ai pas de
réponse précise à cette question je
pense d'ailleurs que l'idée en tant que
tels que l'idée l'âge pivot n'est pas en
soi une mauvaise idée entre les cas
l'idée qu'on est un âge de départ à la
retraite qu'ils puissent évoluer en
fonction de la concertation et du
dialogue qui aura lieu au regard des
données disponibles sur la durée de vie
l'espérance de vie tout ça mérite d'être
raid hélas plus tôt et un super beau
c'est aussi faux le clae chacun
entendent l'âge pivot veut dire une
baisse des pensions versées à chaque
citoyen qui parent c'est pour ça que je
suis pas savoir un jeu de rôle devient
alors le progrès font défaut mais au
fait que l'âge de départ la brède puisse
être modulable en fonction des données
disponibles avant la promenade et c'est
la dernière joueuse
donc la dernière chose c'est que suis
d'accord avec vous sur le fait que le
projet qu'on nous propose aujourd'hui
est excessivement centralisé et que
c'est un problème notamment du point de
vue de la justice
évidemment quand on parle aux gens des
régimes spéciaux ils imaginent saison au
terme de complexité
mais en réalité évidemment il faut
prendre en compte la pénibilité dans le
travail nous ne sommes pas tous égaux
par rapport au tribunal et l'idée qu'un
euro cotisé vaut 1 euro pour la retraite
me paraît être sources potentiellement
d'injustice et de grandes difficultés ça
c'est intéressant parce que chez les
airs c'est pas forcément partagé par
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
mais même chez les socialistes alors à
l'assemblée la semaine le de revient de
sa ténacité ce soir s'échangeant facile
regarder la clique en marche
par contre il ya un débat démocratique
et ça il faut pas il faut classe ici
jean paul delevoye le premier ministre
d'autres ministres les ambassadeurs
retraite de l'assemblée nationale font
un tour de france pour rencontrer les
citoyens pour débattre avec eux de façon
publique la preuve c'est que jean paul
delvaux est encore à metz ce vendredi
invité par les médias pour discuter avec
les citoyens
parce que justement on veut pas se
précipiter et expliquer aussi où est ce
qu'on va aller parce que la retraite
aujourd'hui vous dites qu a pas besoin
de la modifier tout de suite
certes est pas tout de suite mais
pendant les dix quinze ou vingt
prochaines années le système actuel est
défectueux sera d'effectuer donc on doit
le préparer pour une transition bien le
président l'a dit ça va se faire sur 10
ou 15 ans françois xavier gens viennent
avec difficulté soit on est d'accord
mais je pense que pour le coup je je
voudrais dire à quel point il suffit pas
de discuter avec les gens pour faire
vivre débat démocratique la démocratie
suppose qu'une majorité assume de façon
claire une orientation et le travail de
concertation il a déjà eu d'une certaine
manière le travail qu'a fait jean paul
delevoye
c'était quoi alors il l'a fait avec des
syndicats avec les différentes branches
où il l'a pas fait avec tous les
citoyens là on donne la parole aux
citoyens c'est demandé la preuve on l'a
vu siècle et pas uniquement en valais
ont élu la légère inverse
je suis sensible et panique surtout
surtout un français comme comme beaucoup
d'autres je suis enseignant je ne
comprends rien de ce qui se dessine pour
ma part je ne sais pas ce qu'il faut
soutenir aux critiques et je ne sais
même pas où on nous conduit et je trouve
pas ça qui est à savoir le manège de la
place de la france en europe du point de
vue économique parce que emmanuel macron
là-dessus à une proposition il a dit je
veux faire de la france la championne
économique de l'europe et de l'europe en
entier au niveau mondial mais là on a vu
que derrière la france était passée
devant l'allemagne sur les
investissements industriels et de
recherche et de développement même
devant l'angleterre où les premières on
est premiers pays
pardon au niveau européen sur le sujet
on a des investissements qui se font de
plus en plus dans ce qu'on appelle la
deep tech ou la fraise avec la french
tech donc sur les logiciels et sur le
miller pharmacie qu le numérique prend
beaucoup de plus en plus de place
d'ailleurs on sait que ça prendra de
plus en plus de place dans le monde
industriel on sait qu'on a beaucoup
d'industries qui n'avait pas pris deux
mois le la transition au numérique et
technologique sur les vingt dernières
années elles se feront tout doucement
que les robots qui arrivent mais même
avec le maintien des emplois donc toutes
ces choses là avance au fur et à mesure
on voit que tout seul on pourra pas y
arriver on a besoin d'une politique
européenne adaptée donc c'est ce qui est
dit d'or je pense que tu irais breton
serait un meilleur candidat pour
représenter cette partie là au niveau du
numérique et la transition économique
est ce que le parlement européen sur les
prochaines squatté par c'est la
commission industrie est ce que le
parlement européen et vous même allez
travailler justement sur le
développement économique et sortir des
sujets que nous avons jusqu'à maintenant
simplement sur la fiscalité mais bien
sûr l'investissement technologique
l'investissement numérique et donner les
moyens à numéros peine de voir se
développer son sujet bien sûr et ça pour
le coup c'est je crois une priorité
qu'on partage ensemble il faut qu'on se
donne les moyens de notre vitalité
économique pour l'avenir et jusque là
l'union européenne a trop souvent été
reconnaissons le elle a trop souvent été
uniquement motivée par une forme de
dogme du libre-échange qu'il fallait
faire appliquer de manière finalement de
négatifs comme si son travail était
d'abord de faire respecter des normes au
lieu de positivement se donner les
moyens d'avancer
moi je vais être rapporteur par exemple
sur le fond européen de défense c'est la
première fois que l'union européenne
dans un secteur industriel se donne les
moyens d'investir et de mettre de
l'argent public sur la table pour faire
vivre une industrie une chaîne de
valeurs considérées comme stratégiques
pour notre autonomie stratégique besoins
différents mais sur les normales à
différents pays contre fabrique un seul
n ont rien à voir aussi ce fonds là sur
l'énergie je crois qu'un des secteurs
sur lequel l'europe est attendue la
transition énergétique
on est là dessus très en retard et quand
on regarde ce que fait la chine
aujourd'hui c'est très inquiétant aller
là où je partage votre point de vue
c'est vrai que depuis trop longtemps
l'europe empêchent parfois des géants
européens au nom d'un libéralisme
d'ailleurs extérieur quand on voit qu'on
se fait tailler des croupières donc il
faut qu'elle soit retrouve cette
capacité d'intervention de financement
et pour créer des gens des géants
européens pour concrets de part de
marché nous sauver nos emplois
ce point fait je crois qu'on est on est
on est prêt à travailler de façon
positive sur ces sujets c'est très
important
maintenant je me permets de revenir sur
l'idée de créer en france une forme de
deux pays champion d'europe au champion
du monde du développement économique
pourquoi pas mais on ne peut pas écarter
c'est d'ailleurs nécessaire mais on va
écarter les obstacles que la france se
met à elle-même sur ce chemin je
prétends pas une toute l'année dernière
pour les élections européennes je
continue d'aller tous les jours sur le
terrain je vois à quel point nous avons
par notre obsession de la réglementation
des normes par la complexité de notre
administration par le poids écrasant de
notre fiscalité nous avons la fiscalité
la plus élevée de tous les pays de le
céder au ce sont des sujets là pour
présenter leur permanisation d'être dans
une fabuleuse et laisser faire et on a
tenté aussi de fuite en avant qui ne qui
ne kim qui n'a rien résolu nos jeux la
germanie bon il ya une erreur sur d'être
sur ce que le parlement est du moins le
gouvernement ont beaucoup travaillé pour
permettre aux entreprises françaises de
se développer plus facilement
il ya eu la réforme au niveau du code du
travail il ya en plus la loi pas qui est
arrivé qu'ils enlèvent les parties des
effets de seuil
on a eu un débat aussi sur la
comptabilité et les mandataires
autour il ya eu un débat sur le fait que
les l'impô t c était trop élevé il a été
positionné pour être baissée dans le
temps et les entreprises savent comment
il va baisser les charges patronales ou
si les championnats elle aussi donc on
accompagne l'entreprise mais on peut pas
à la fois palier dans n'importe comment
j'ai sombré dans le déni de réel que dès
que les choses aient été tenté c'est
certain mais on est encore très loin
d'avoir résolu les grands problèmes qui
se présentent à nous aujourd'hui je
m'occupe d'emploi des jeunes dans ma
ville je suis président de la mission
locale de ma ville je vois pour les pme
de ma ville pour les petits artisans les
commerçants
la grande difficulté à recruter et
notamment par exemple à cause du coût du
travail qui est exorbitant dans la lutte
et on voit très bien et on va tenir pas
bien sûr que si tardive de la demande ce
que pour beaucoup de l'entreprise quand
vous regardez avec eux pour investir ou
pour embaucher ce qu'ils disent est
temps que je n'ai pas de marcher je n'ai
pas de demande en face je ne le sont
aujourd'hui
et ne se développe pas parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens de faire face à ce
que ça représente les industriels ce
sera des heures et des heures de débat
au parlement européen notamment si j'ai
bien compris vous vouliez racheter mal
parler de quelqu'un que certainement
françois-xavier bellamy connais vous
parliez de 10 à sin belattar tout à
l'heure une hiérachie tu es mal il veut
vous parler d'eric zemmour non mais je
pense que c'est un thèse à la transition
non parce que en fait je vais je vous
entends doute à l'heure et je crois que
vous avez eu raison ce qui s'est passé
tout à l'heure donc ce qu'on peut
appeler une forme d'attentât je ne sais
pas quels sont les thèmes qu'il faut
qualifier mais ils n'attaquent pour une
attaque mais je dis donc une personne
qui va tirer sur des personnes qui vont
prier dont je rappelle qu'il ya doublé
c'est vous l'avait condamné je crois
qu'on peut que tous deux condamnés et
vous avez raison de dire d'ailleurs qu'à
un moment donné il ya un climat qui peut
engendrer cela et on voit bien que
certains qui depuis plusieurs années
porte un discours deux aides
un tir de violence un discours de rejet
il ya parfois des gens qui passent aux
actes et en ce moment nous avons un
débat en france notamment sur la
question d'eric zemmour et nonobstant
qu'il était condamné pour n 1 de ses
stations à la haine raciale a par
ailleurs aujourd'hui libre antenne sur
un média qui il a déjà tenu des propos
qui pourraient être pénalement
répréhensible moi je suis pour mener un
combat politique contre lui j'aimerais
vous entendre sur eric zemmour est ce
que vous partager sa vision
quel est votre point de vue est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi pour
combattre politiquement eric zemmour et
sa logique de haine et ses propos de
haine parce que moi je pense qu'il faut
unis la france et ne pas la fragmenter
voilà donc c'est pour ça que je voulais
vous entendre sur eric zemmour d'abord
la prochaine c'est quand vous parlez
d'un discours de haine qui pousse
certains à passer à l'acte et à
commettre des faits de violence moi je
pense à l'islam radical
moi je suis aujourd'hui parmi les jours
et pour aujourd'hui dans notre pays
je parle des communautaires des
communautaristes du jihadisme aussi
d'être des identitaires en fait ils sont
quelque part quelque part enfin en rond
de saint cloud c'est parce qu'on sait
pas ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
resituer la question françois lamy
mettez vous convient pardonnez moi d'y
répondre c'est quand même là je ne
pouvais pas mais je suis frappé
vous pouvez pas me taxer que je ne
serais je le regarderai l'un n'est pas
l'autre je peux vous faire un long
développement sur la fondation
permanente que je fais sur les habitants
du carré jaude en double je veux je n'ai
simplement dire qu'on ne peut pas mettre
les deux choses sur le même sol en rien
sur nos pensées vous venez de dire les
attentats islamistes et identitaire
désolé mais aujourd'hui bien les dates
entre islamistes et dentelle je voulais
parler des communautaristes et des
djihadistes
je verrai mis sur le même plan pardon
les enjeux bien que vous essayez de ne
pas répondre
moi je crois que je condamne vous en
parler d'autres manger dessus une des
victimes directes du xiii du 13 novembre
mais puisque notre jeu vous dire donc
moi je n'ai pas de souci avec ça donc le
comité évidemment la même quand je vous
pose la question sur monsieur zemmour
effet les propos de haine jeu est-ce que
c'est pas l'un aux autres je vous parle
de sa revue dans la région la même
congrégation de évidemment des attentats
terroristes
je veux simplement dire que il ya d'un
côté les discours de haine qui
produisent de la violence de l'autre
côté il ya des positions politiques
qu'on peut contester avec des arguments
dans le champ politique et et vous ne
regardez que zemmour prod propose un
discours politique et en ce que le comté
ce condamné arguments un damné la
condamnez moi je travaille dans une
ville at il été condamné pour incitation
à la haine raciale
il a été condamné est-ce que les propos
qu'il a tenus notamment sur un général
mais encore une fois la question c'est
comment est-ce que si on n'est pas
d'accord avec vous comment est ce qu on
lui répond par la raison maintenant je
veux dire mon sentiment comment ce qui
me ce qui me
il ya deux choses qui me pose problème
d'un côté ce qui me pose problème c'est
oui c'est vrai je l'assumé parfaitement
le fait qu'aujourd'hui certains
s'émeuvent plus mettons que je j'entends
bien que vous n'êtes pas dans ce cas-là
mais certains s'émeuvent plus de ce que
dit eric zemmour que du fait que
effectivement la haine et la violence
qui traverse notre pays elles sont
aujourd'hui du côté du communautarisme
islamiste du côté du jihadisme et saint
paul c'est ça le danger donc très bien
ça c'est quand même un truc qui est
quand même quelque chose qui me gène qui
attend ça m'étonnait de la deuxième
chose c'est que c'est le point sur
lequel je serai en désaccord avec eric
zemmour je l'assumé parfaitement et
je n'ai aucun problème pour le dire
c'est que je crois que la chose
principale aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
comment reconstruire le lien comment
retisser le lien d'une société qui est
en train de se déliter je le dis comme
enseignant je le disais tout à l'heure
la grande question c'est comment donner
la france a et méritait pas ce travail
là et je crois qu'effectivement il ya un
danger très grand qui nous menacent
aujourd'hui qui serait celui de ne
parler de l'islam que comme d'une force
de fracturation ou 2 ou 2 ou 2 ou de
dispersion de il appelle la polo meurt
c'est à dire ça à vrai et ça vous ne
pouvez pas nier qu'il a pas dit jamais
non dans le débat va savourer ce qu'il
est je vous avais aussi 2 et sochaux
deux oreilles après vos propos si vous
en verrez la vidéo soit condamné par la
justice mais c'est qu'eric zemmour si
l'on tient des propositions politiques
là qu'on le vende sur ces news face à
monsieur cuisine par deux fois il a tenu
des propos mais a pas d'appel au meurtre
c'est incroyable va s'arrêter là si je
vous dis on va s'arrêter là on va
s'arrêter là ce qu'on n'a pas la même
les vous n'avez jamais entendu c'est mal
merci le de victime elle est revenue sur
ce plateau et on va maintenant entamer
la dernière partie cette émission
auditions publiques
yves thréard du figaro et le regard
distrait rebond soit arrive
bonsoir francis à lui salué ses coûts
alors je vous ai écouté longuement je
vous écoute et toutes les exclues
l'émission et je dirais vous êtes un
vigile en souriant sire que le sourire
ne vous quitte jamais ce qui est assez
agréable d'ailleurs de vous regarder et
de vous écouter parce que vous êtes
toujours dans l'articulation la
rhétorique walt professeur de
philosophie mais vous êtes vigilant sur
tous les sujets qui ont été évoqués ce
soir c'est à dire la pma la laïcité
l'europe et tous les autres sujets vous
n'êtes ni pour ni contre
ce qui ne veut pas dire que vous soyez
comme macro et et pas du tout vous êtes
toujours dans la méfiance mais dans la
méfiance articulé en disant faut se
méfier de la loi bioéthique
il faut la laïcité jeu on peut quand
même avoir quelques inquiétudes sur les
retraites
vous avez dit que vous ne compreniez pas
grand chose d'ailleurs comme beaucoup de
français mon avis mais là aussi ça peut
être inquiétant pour l'avenir et pour
qu'on n'a pas carrément reporter l'âge
de départ à la retraite
et puis sur tous les autres sujets vous
étiez un petit peu comme ça alors moi je
voudrais qui complète un petit peu ces
sujets pour que vous d'équité écouter ce
rythme je vais dire oui mais très franc
et direct peut-être pas inquiétante
d'ailleurs l'avenir des républicains
c'est votre parti vous ont choisi vous
les avez emmené à leurs vaillants au
casse pipe
non aux élections européennes vous êtes
déçu de votre score bien sûr tout à fait
j'ai quand je savais que ce serait très
difficile quand j'ai été investi les
sondages donnaient le parti à 8 % aux
européennes donc je savais que ce serait
difficile
la déception a été à la mesure de
l'espoir que la campagne a suscité on a
vécu une très belle campagne
vraiment c'est le paradoxe de ce
résultat on a vu partout en france des
gens venir à notre à notre rencontre et
nous témoigner leur
leur adhésion et ça s'est traduit dans
les sondages et les sondages ont montré
que notre campagne portée ont tenté des
résultats et donc la déception est vive
parce que on a cru qu'on avait percé on
a cru où on a l'impression que vous avez
pris un peu de recul
vous nous avez même pas dit pour qu'il
vous aviez voté la présidence des
républicains mais je j'ai expliqué de
très nombreuses fois pourquoi je ne
soutenait pas un candidat pas vous allez
voter mais pas que sur sa coque non je
ne dirais pas pour la même raison que
j'ai exprimée pendant cette campagne est
dommage mais non mais c'est normal
encore une fois et je ne suis pas le
seul dans ce cas là tous ceux qui sont
chefs de groupes parlementaires ou
président d'une institution important
d'accord c'est le cas de gérard larcher
c4 bruno retailleau n'ont pas non plus
en tant destruction du parti j'espère
pouvoir apporter ma contribution autant
que je pourrais être utile
humblement vous savez moi je suis alors
fui à ce que christian jacob ne prétend
pas non plus right man at the right
place
je suis sûr et c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle je n'ai pas pris parti
pendant la campagne que que parce que
les trois candidats étaient de valeur et
je suis sûr que christian jacob avec
lequel j'ai noué un lien fort pendant
cette campagne européenne accra peut
jouer un rôle de rassembleur pour la
reconstruction de cette famille
politique parce qu'on en a besoin et
parce que la france en a besoin
alors il ya peut-être une chose qui pour
vous et essentiel je ne sais pas vous
allez nous le dira christian jacob c'est
un homme qui a été très content très
longtemps aux côtés de jacques chirac et
jacques chirac disait il ya une barrière
étanche qu'on ne peut pas franchir entre
le front national à l'époque c'était
front national donc le rassemblement
national l'ump de l'époque et maintenant
les républicains c'est votre point de
vue bon point de vue c'est que je ne me
sens pas de base commune avec le
rassemblement national
quand j'ai été désigné pour être chef de
file à l'élection européenne marine le
pen a expliqué que c'était la france des
bourgeois contre la france populaire qui
était représenté par jordan bardella
fait il ya un discours post marxiste y
compris sur la question des retraites
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
y compris sur la question du salaire
minimum il ya un discours de de fiction
qui est une manière de mentir aux
finances avec lui et rennes et de les
dresser les uns contre les voir au sens
de la lettre de cette espèce de
de résurrection de la lutte des classes
n'est pas inquiet voire l'alliance
intéressant c'est clair mais c'est parce
que l'instrument pas de doctrine commune
on n'a pas de vision des choses
je crois qu est ce que vous êtes sur la
même doctrine que christian jacob parce
qu'on voit pas sa doctrine
on voit qui veut pas s'allier avec le
rassemblement national on voit qu'il
veut faire un très large rassemblement
le plus large possible évidemment le
parti s'est beaucoup rétréci mais quels
sont les trois mots magiques pour
refaire les républicains vous disiez
tout à l'heure un d'un j'ai vu qu'elle
était votre expression un vigile en
souriant
ça je crois que je crois que cette
vigilance elle peut définir peut-être la
droite au fond ce qui me moi qui m'a
toujours paru qui m'a toujours laissé
sceptique dans le maquereau nisme c'est
une espèce d'optimisme de principe
l'idée qu'être en marche était forcément
une garantie que on allait en marchant
vers un progrès mais en fait nous avons
reçu des biens qui sont infiniment
précieux infiniment fragile
c'est cette culture commune qui n'est
pas effectivement garantis pour
l'éternité
c'est aussi cette nature dont nous
héritons et ce qu'il définit la droite
historiquement ce qui la définit depuis
la révolution française c'est cette
prudence cette attention aux grands
équilibres du réel peut-être là où de
l'autre côté le progressisme c'est
l'idée que la marche en avant est
toujours destiné à nous garantir un
avenir radieux
moi je crois au contraire que être
capable d'aimer ce que nous avons reçues
pour pouvoir le transmettre
être capable d'être prudents et
vigilants sur ces grands écrivains
demandes que nous recevons
c'est une manière peut-être pas
seulement de conserver mais de
transmettre ce qui mérite d'être sauvé
pour les autres il ya une figure connue
dans est d'ailleurs qu'on voit ici
connu dans le paysage politique à droite
françois barois qui est l'héritier de
chirac lui aussi au combien qui fait son
retour dans la direction du républicain
- au comité stratégique
c'est pour vous quelqu'un qui pourrait
compter en 2022 à des élections
présidentielles la france à barran
évidemment quelqu'un qui compte dans
cette famille politique et il a le
profil
j'ai eu la chance de
de le connaître à l'occasion de la
campagne des élections européennes de
recevoir son ciseau vient aussi pour de
maintenant je sais pas du tout s'il
souhaitera être candidat je ne sais pas
mais en fait il nous reste d'abord à
traiter ces questions de fond que vous
évoquez si justement un resto je ne dis
pas qu'il n'aurait pas le profil je dis
juste que lui-même encore une fois ne
nous a pas dit s'il paraît alors se
présenter ou non ces mais évidemment que
c'est une figure qui compte c'est une
question de méthode et de forme mais en
fait c'est une question de fond est ce
qu'il faut une élection primaire pour
choisir le candidat des républicains
avec jean présidentielle et si ces
primaires existait ce qu'elle doit être
ouverte
ça c'est une question pour le coup très
complexe autant j'espère avoir répondu
le mieux possible aux questions
précédentes je serai je ne prétendrai
pas être capable de trancher ce sujet
est bien ou pas il me semble que encore
une fois d'abord le point central c'est
de faire un travail de fond sur les
idées sur le projet sur la vision qu'on
veut partager et que si on ne fait pas
ce travail là quoi qu'il arrive primero
non la droite sortira de l'histoire la
deuxième chose que je peux dire c'est
que je ne sais pas exactement à titre
personnel voyez on a le droit de dire
parfois qu'on n'a pas eu tout un million
clair je ne sais pas exactement quel est
le meilleur système pour identifier un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
tous leurs défauts mais je me permets de
beauté un peu en touche parce qu'un
effet je n'ai pas de neuner pas deux
alors ce sera au moins c'est dit trois
poules mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les
raisons doit primer et le lutteur trois
petites questions rapides et très rapide
c'est sûr si vous êtes très mécontent
que vos petits camarades députés
eurodéputés député européen pour parler
français des républicains qui
fréquentent assez peu les assemblées
parlementaires l'assemblée parlementaire
européenne annonce au contraire c'est
une transaction mais pas du tout non au
contraire on a une délégation très
présente depuis le début de ce mandat
avant elle est vraiment je ne vais pas
révolutionner les informations non non
non alors d'accord
rachida dati bonne candidate pour les
républicains à paris bonne candidate
oui je crois que dans tous les cas il
faut il faut manifestement quelqu'un qui
puisse avoir la notoriété nécessaire
pour faire en sorte que la droite soit
représentée dans le temps réel à paris
et donc si elle souhaite être candidate
c'est ce qu'a décidé alors de l'éthique
pour cet accord troisième question
patrick balkany a été condamné
deux reprises en correctionnelle il
avait demandé une libération
il l'a obtenue pour une de ces
condamnations la première d'entre elles
qui est sec de fraude au fisc fraude
fiscale
vous trouvez ça est ce qu'il pourrait se
représenter aux élections municipales
c'est ce que ça vous dérangerait ce que
ça apporterait valeurs morales alors
qu'il a été condamné en tout à 10 ans
devrait être de deux prises ne partent
pas de réclusion quand on est condamné
et qu'on n'a pas été condamnée à être
éligible on peut factuellement se
représenter c'est ensuite aux électeurs
de décider
je ne vais pas commenter une décision de
justice elle ni accablé balkany dit il
est très clair que moi je crois que la
politique doit susciter la confiance des
français que cette confiance est
profondément abîmée
je le vis comme j'en ai lu je suis tous
les jours
exposé basket à la méfiance et la grâce
de révolte que c'est ça le tennis est
pas la politique et je crois que il faut
avoir sans doute là là là certainement
là une retenue
en tous les cas se sont engagés pour
tenter de reconstruire cette confiance
nécessaire ça me parait ça me paraît
indispensable aujourd'hui ça
circonvolutions des enfants d'avoir une
réponse merci c'est parti c'est quoi
votre vers steve merci forces vives et
la merci à vous pour votre ouverte au
public
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro live ainsi sur
les comptes twitter de lcp public sénat
bonne semaine merci évidemment à lundi
prochain 19 heures
[Musique]